hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master swat at election and this
is a good test of the bank of course I
have played it before and yes and I
think he declined with this movie yes
and it was an interesting game and the
wind oh that's X things that i have a
problem there just a second you know my
recording does work i had had a message
that mayan and then my disc was forced
it and i just created some disk space ok
93 a bit uncommon hmm I have no idea he
thinks it's kind of logical if i take
this probably even five no pruning out
there 37 so what about that pond can I
cover it for a moment
let's see
just want to be annoying there at the
pond yes yeah I have to I have to do
this problem pawn to d6 I don't want to
see like this should be 746 that's not
going to work yes of course you can do
that but I'm not unhappy that II that I
got that I got the straight and I wonder
if Queen d7 is actually a move 27 Queen
takes and then Queen g4 stuff that's
probably where do i need to get my stuff
developed group we ate at an interesting
move actually I'm threatening look
before wait to see the trick but well it
kind of wins the temple doesn't it okay
now castles good night be six or eight
let's start with this yeah we should be
fate isn't much of a move but Queen a
five maybe 10 96 okay I have to do this
very likely anyway so let's do it
96 9 a-4 would be good maybe equals 92
here we need six maybe
maybe three might also be a good idea
for him yep
preparing see form I didn't see a
dynamic way to play it just playing it a
fondant work and now I cannot move that
match it for 95 or just this one yeah
maybe 94 I don't know this is so
threatening nice to see 695 is the
threat simple chess but is the threat
and if he goes somewhere like be to have
90 form I don't know interesting I'm a
bishop one fa definitely it's not the
greatest piece ever yeah
I have to play croquet 96 doesn't work
now maybe it goes like night a forehand
and I like Queen B 7 that doesn't do
much actually there's actually an idea
of Queen B seven white is that one fine
morning I take yard I don't understand
it why does it work or maybe just gives
it i mean it's possible i'm not sure
that the night is that fantastic night
is always annoying of course to become
flits chess the nights are dangerous
ok quindi for Navy for this 47 difficult
difficult to organize this Quincy six
Quincy one Navy
h 5 h was my idea threatens to take now
ok so I'll then queen of two actually
should check check check no no just
ponder this check ok black for six times
oh my time was even worse and now I'm
winning this of course but I had no I
didn't see that my time was so bad tough
game yeah I think it was probably equal
for a long time at least that's why I
think should be roughly equal yeah I
wasn't so unhappy here that just got
traded you should be notoriously tricky
tricky piece to use I think this is just
okay yeah I'm not really sure here
taking was an option that I didn't like
that so much I he gave the pawn and he's
got the strong light on d5 that is
compensation keep pressing the wrong
button I had that look at all fairly
King daddy logical Knight f6 always got
23 check okay yeah that winsome check
yep it was a big opportunity
check check yeah now keeping the balance
somewhat and now we had eight seconds I
didn't really see that it was so little
so little time they are Queenie one of
course wins he's got no King roof and
clean up to their safety as a changeable
okay okay no time at all I mean yeah it
was just a crapshoot yeah you can take
the look and so on that it's just we
both had no time at the end this is
sometimes the issue with a non increment
on there you have a very tense game that
takes time and at the end it's basically
decided by tossing a coin IAM at the end
ok guys thanks for watching